okay for those on the livestream welcome
back to this evenings design review and
documentation session for some software
engineering functionality for the
upcoming version of Wolff language and
when we left off we were looking at
Network packet capture and related
functions so I think we just finished
off doing our documentation Network
packet capture and next up we're doing
Network packet recording
and I think our what we have from here
on out our what we'll be doing is we'll
be finishing off the network packets
stuff and then we will be working on
external evaluate and web unit and
automation of website stuff whether
we're comment from the twitch stream
from earlier promiscuous mode typically
requires to be user rights to modify a
network interface and that Mathematica
crashes I'd like to ensure that the
interface resets to whatever mode it was
before that interesting right so so as I
mentioned in the in the twitch chat we
won't ever enable or disable promiscuous
mode that's something that the user will
have to do independently of Mathematica
so that's not something you worried
about okay fine all right let's go ahead
and look at tum ho by the way network
packet capture I think we might just for
amusement point into audio capture
service because an analogous function
and that means I should go ahead and
um point back there I mean it's kind of
weird but but the fact is for example
for what we're doing right now on zoom
you could actually see weirdly you know
you can see our audio packets
you
and
have we got let me just check whether
the audio recording function is in
evidence yet
ouch okay and Karla remember we are
changing audio records to audio
recording yes I'll track that down okay
and I'm gonna go ahead and um
Network packet cap recording in the sea
also for this
it's a little bit far for you
for people um okay so you did you put in
the chords information on that works by
heterosexual
you
you
is this how we want to do it as opposed
to having two arguments here time and
then the service we could have two two
arguments let's see how audiorecord does
it
sure the last time we looked at this you
want to hit for the advice
oh you know what I think we agreed on
how audio recording was going to do that
and I think we need to make sure that
this is consistent with that okay so
right now they have a max duration thing
but we're getting rid of that and it'll
just be and this is this by the way
should point to device what is it called
device anchors yes device read time
series
you
okay and this
also point two I mean this one wants to
point to some of these other things here
like all of those probably all of those
things in the middle there right network
interfaces default network interface
host lookup ping time constant why there
be any less relevant to this than that
[Music]
you
see
um
[Music]
um okay and that's now what's the our
log of this here device is there an
analog of the capture no there isn't
there isn't an interactive device
capture thing by the way that perhaps
should be
don't you think yeah I mean I guess the
Vice chapter would be the the intuitive
name but I mean it is a little bit
different considering if you're gonna
have a device capture it should work
with with any device object and so then
the first argument has to be the device
object right right right but then it
will give you an interface and you would
basically capture according to the time
specified by the GUI by the way notice
that the structure of this is a little
different device where it's got to have
the device first
right that's why I was saying we really
need to know how audio recording is
working um let's see was it wasn't Carlo
there was a meeting today what am i
confused here um Carlo Giacometti was
going to be part of some meeting maybe
that was a meeting that got moved from
maybe tomorrow morning can you see if
you can find him see if he can join us
here he probably knows what what the
story is with audio recording I'll try
his West coast-based so I think he's
around um
okay
you
okay the rest of this is all identical
yeah I mean just replaced record after
my let's go tuned dollar network
interfaces
[Music]
now
you
okay network interfaces are specified
network interfaces are specified by
device but specified by strings
corresponding to a UNIX device is that
correct
is it like Devi and zero is that the no
no they're not no I'll specify rings
there no I mean you can say something
such as yen there we go
on UNIX devices it's it's something
different on Windows what is it what
kind of a thing is in Windows I mean
it's like wireless network number one
there wireless network number two or
okay I mean generic things like that by
string names such as that's not relevant
that's not what we would say here
okay
once a refer this to network packet
capture
what about system information does it
have any of this information in it it
probably should if it doesn't issue okay
I don't think it does so I'll make a
note right somebody should put that in
and totally high priority but it should
be put in
at work packet Network packet recording
you
anything else this should refer to let's
take a look at the appropriate guide
page um sewer system information let's
look at my thing here okay
you
systems set up
you
let me see
[Music]
you
Oh from the audio team you just think
I'm trying to think of who we can I
panic Carlo isn't available um
who else is in the audio team who would
be available at this time of day
[Music]
hum we're going to have to pick this up
tomorrow
unfortunately this that thing about
audio recording because we need to make
sure that's consistent okay okay so so
what I was saying up towards the top
under where it says dollar version
dollar system I think yeah so somewhere
in there right because it's a very
similar thing
we are system capabilities but where is
how device what what's the device
finding devices what's that kinda
devices function is just find devices
what's dollar services integrated
services that kind of thing
okay
you
let's see we should probably have this
under
you
this is probably under hardware
configuration it's probably a separate
section here
you
why should that guy
the bottom here system hardware
configuration and that would contain
um what is the thing for controllers for
that definitely contains find devices
yeah it's like a confined it there's
it's a function
you
so yeah it's just controller information
you know I'm not
- for network interface sir I'm just
gonna do that okay and this will want to
be covered also on the page about
network actually let's do that right now
before and then we still have default
network interface to document
go to the page let me just look
okay
let's go to the page about Network so
it's good aware of a host lookup as is
included
network programming seems rather
relevant to this
reading from sockets write into sockets
okay so where would we include this
packet
I think it might even actually need its
own section I don't know if we have
appropriate section here well we've
certainly got utility say no no we want
to set a separate section yes
by the way dalla network-connected is
highly relevant oh yes
yes we should include that and sea
otters
you
you
I don't know whether
system information
let's ping a book you do we keep that
no it's not really there
we decided that wasn't interesting and
by the way should we did we keep URL
response time I don't I don't I mean
somebody might be working on it it's not
in master so okay there's another very
important thing that's here which is
dollar machine addresses right yes and
some other dollar signs that might be
relevant is dollar audio input devices
dollar audio output device and hold on
hold on hold on hold on
and we also got cameras just a second
here okay darling network connected so
this and other machine addresses we
definitely want our network interfaces
and we also I think by the time we're
talking about machine addresses you
might as well have network packet
capture here also
because by the time you care what your
machine addresses you might care about
that do you agree or do not agree I
agree I think network packet capture is
logical to have on machine addresses ok
requests her address
is that
that only works in the cloud like for an
API evaluation okay
okay fair enough what about the socket
stuff pointing the socket stuff to the
packet to the some network I would say
maybe socket listen okay
pocket pointing foot for network packet
capture yeah I think maybe both ways
socket listen to network packet capture
and the other way that my time useful
you know you start at a synchronous
socket listen and then you know you're
doing some web server thing and you want
to see all the packets that are
transmitted transmitted
and that will work without any stuff
that doesn't exist right now
you
okay soccer
so let's point socket listen back to
network
you
you
how are we going to make sure that this
device capture thing gets discussed
who's that for is that for Igor I would
say for ya
okay so Carla can you take that sure
maybe we should remove audio capture
from here what do you think is it -
irrelevant no I mean I think I think
it's pretty pretty relevant I mean it's
the same kind of capture interface I
think though is image capture so as you
know okay it gets one a little bit of
the way though all right fine um okay
let's see where we were on
so you are our response time does exist
that seems relevant is it relevant
Paquette recording
I mean it's relevant in so far as you
know anything that is the URL related
and okay so let's go back to the guide
page here network programming whatever
it was
okay
time-constrained
okay so so let's have a separate section
here called network packet capture
you want to just maybe call it at work
packets or if you want network packet
capture
you
um
[Music]
you
you
well let's think
you
um what is this call this is called
let's call this low-level Network
operations
you
and then let's say
you
you
capture information on all packets
you
you
you
and now we
Paquette recording I think we need to
have um
sorry what was the thing here in
addition to these we want ah let me see
um I was thinking
Oh what was I thinking here
um
gosh
let's see
and I think we should just
there
we were looking at network connected
by the way network-connected should
surely point to network packet capture
because or network packet recording
because if you really want to know
whether your network is doing anything
look at the packets see what I'm saying
yeah yeah no I agree I think Network
packet recording is probably more useful
thing there
you
you
oh I was thinking URL response time is
that relevant to its sort of relevant to
the network packet business because
because some it is really because you
can see what the actual response time is
you can see stuff go out and come back
right yeah I mean I wasn't thinking it
makes sense insofar as you know if
you're doing kind of network debugging
kind of things you know you want to see
what the response time the website is
and maybe you want to see the actual
packets that you know get responded to
yeah it's very much a network debugging
you
that comes after ping time were putting
in
you
you
okay so now you may actually just see
that in action so if I say URL response
time
of oops
so that will be WWF calm right actually
so let me let me do this I'm just
curious whether this works and this
would not be a bad example to use so how
would I do so if I say
by doing this how do I do how do I get
this to show me the these packets going
out during the time that I've got my
network packet capture happening right
so so I mean the real thing I mean the
real way you do this is you do you know
submit you do a submit of network packet
capture then you'd run your URL response
time and then you do like task finished
result so why shouldn't I have session
submit
so well what is it cooler I want to do a
local evaluate right which is the which
local know what I want is something
which is like by the way if I do I want
to do it in a local sub process because
it doesn't really make any difference
where this is happening right you know I
would do it in I mean that the way to do
it right now would be local submit you
do local submit of network packet
recording say you know five seconds I
mean I know it would take that long but
okay and then what do you just have a
low eight that and then do euro response
time and then do you know percent
eighteen of evaluation results or
something oh come on the thing has died
we mean I feel like you should still be
able to get well so is okay so I guess
you did you'd have to do with their
handler functions I feel like you should
still be able to get the result that
seems wrong it seems wrong yes I mean it
seems like you should be able to do at a
local evaluate just like you can do a
cloud evaluate and I thought you could
do something like that
hmm submits let's look at the CSO's
you know I mean look one way we could do
it could we do this let's try this
you
oh my god that's pretty wild what's
about to happen is deeply wild
yeah I mean so I probably eating my
machine alive I I did test it and it
should run in parallel you'll get very
similar datasets because you can
actually capture be capturing multiple
and on the same interface it will not be
exactly the same you know it won't but
it'll be very similar overlapping by the
way that's probably what you should use
for in each examples for a network
packet recording mm-hmm it's parallel
evaluate of those things okay
what is that vn/ic one what is that who
knows
that is interesting that is that is some
kind of interface that has nothing to do
with that's an I bet that some kind of
internal interface on the machine
mincing the Phoenix I think is something
to do with like a virtual virtual
machine yeah right but it probably has
to do with the fact that we're running
on 12 cores here and it has to send the
data to so if I take % 21 sub 1 sub 1
that port what's the what's what is that
stuff well it's going st. st. port yeah
well I'm curious what that is I'm just
going to look it up for one second
actually yeah so that that could be
a virtual network okay well anyway you
could point this out to Roman he might
actually find it useful
anyway that that is definitely a way to
get a parallel I suspect if I did
parallel evaluate
on these parallel kernels I wonder if I
can just say number one for example buy
that dollar colonel ID
you
you
if I just say comma one yeah I can do
that that that would be how I would do
this this is kind of ID one and this is
how I would do it I would just say
Network look I could do this comma one
that semicolon
[Music]
you are response time
right and I claim
you
I don't really understand how this will
work
all right so that's two
Ekans
you
something really weird is going I'm not
sure this is doing the right thing I'm
not sure this will work because I'm not
sure it dispatches those
ah yeah okay oh what's that is a
loopback link
well this is more exotic when we do this
parallel evaluate we get some much more
exotic things
yeah I mean I think that a lot of that
now weird activity is actually math like
right because you know they're various
you know you have to start the
connection and then send the expression
and things like that and then it'll have
like keepalive type things you know this
is super interesting I mean this should
be given to the um yeah okay anyway all
right let's keep going here um so we
wanted we have to loop back talking loop
back links to the guide page here but
had we finished we haven't done default
network interface here
and then we needed to finish that guide
page correct yes the system information
guide page
you
one okay gives the default network
interface
I'm used on your machine
Alice
for curves
you
okay
so this probably
has many fewer of these things this is
probably
but we'll edit it down
you
okay so we've got Donnell network
interfaces
that work packet capture Network packet
recording and Dola network connected and
I guess I guess it's okay we can have
system information there okay all right
let's go back over here to
relevance of machine addresses seems
like it should be referenced on the
network interfaces thing yes where
should it be in the list I would say
after Network connected that was exactly
where I was thinking okay dollar machine
addresses
okay
the fault
you
okay all right
back to our guide page over here
you
how do we have machine addresses do we
have that on here
we do not
you
you
well I think we should have
we should have a section here called
network
network information you know
and that should contain
Sheen
domains I think the Machine domains
dollar machine addresses
you
well the very first thing here is dollar
Network connect
don't think we have anywhere here
you
and
Dola network interfaces I think
you
and I think we could skip
sir
okay
all right I think that's okay
all right anything more
for this this documentation I mean
wafters over the record thing with some
audio people yep think think that's it
so you looked at the dollar sign network
stuff we looked at actually on this list
here we probably should list machine
addresses and machine since this is
about network programming you kind of
want to know what your machine addresses
don't you you might want to know what
your machine address is it sure would be
yeah I agree
okay so let's put it under the low-level
network operations or should we put it
up here
[Music]
I really don't know maybe I mean if we
have dullard network-connected under
low-level metric options I guess that's
a logical place to put it as well
okay tell a machine domain
until a machine
addresses okay
okay
and
to die to die
I must be once a reference network
Patrick capture but I think that's far
afield from device read time series
I actually would like to reference audio
recording here that seems much more
relevant
actually but prolly both audio recording
you
okay by the way we should make sure that
in the raspberry pie specific
information that we have I wonder if
this is worth putting in that on that
page now that I think about it putting
on the network packet capture style yeah
I think I think people would find it
useful to Ron that's very fast
you
how can we put it
two devices
you
so the section here
network programming or network analysis
I wonder what
things we should include here if we're
going to just we can just list a bunch
of the relevant functions here
what should we list I would say socket
listen would be one of them I guess
network packet recording or capture
whatever not sure which you
view is more cool any all those have
[Music]
maybe Channel listen a channel listening
the channel framework stuff is under
network programming guide so okay and
let's point this at the network
programming okay it's useful I think
alright onward okay I think we got a new
topic is that right what is our next
topic so the next topic is external
evaluate with with web unit okay okay so
again it should be an external it should
be working there is and it's that
documentation what where's the
documentation now a custom page so yeah
I've been working with Brady Martin and
other the docs people about making a new
I can send you the one that I made for
Python okay well is it in there is it in
the source no it's not a tedious yet I
don't think they have finished setting
it up yet but I can quick just send you
by mail fine fine so then show you okay
just one
you
you
okay I just sent the mail so yeah so so
we're working on getting the doc page
you know fleshed out the sections in
that page are both basically done and I
can also I'll also finish I'll send you
this kind of example commands I have for
the web unit stuff so right it is just
very similar to the import format page
you know you've kind of like a general
information occasion but but um
oh I shouldn't edit this right because I
got the Python is uncapitalized there
but but um we also need a bunch of stuff
about what datatypes it supports right
yes yes do you think that should be
another like its own section like data
types like similar there's an options
section um I think so I mean I think
it's gonna be useful for every language
I think it's gonna be just a table ok
one edit okay alright let's see if I can
actually operate this thing so this is
an X kernel right yeah so just first
thing I would just try running find
external evaluators you will probably
see a bunch of messages but it should
still should still work
and it didn't oh yes it's doing
something there should be a big data set
so if it's 4 million that data set or
did it just die it might have just died
I think it just died it crashed okay is
this the only external you have I don't
know um
can I can I find external evaluators
with a more narrow set I mean yeah you
can try just doing python finding still
turn evaluators a Python but me just the
main thing crash that feel like that sub
ones will crash as well
beeps and crashed I think and what's it
doing here I think it's probably
crashing in some yeah I'm not sure where
expression okay all right let me see if
I have an older I can also try the
Mathematica instead of all from desktop
X kernel build and just see whether that
does it
you are very loud typing yes mechanical
keyboard I apologize
you know what that means you mean like a
typewriter no the physical keys are the
sweat the these big switches that are
quite loud
okay that's okay so that did the right
thing and some generalized sense of
right thing
okay so now what you say is I try the
same thing with what with WebKit web
unit what's it called so well as per
your instructions it's now webdriver - -
Chrome
okay that's kind of for that feared um
so I think it's only by the way you
shouldn't if you change that message not
a known system in the external evaluator
framework right I mean it's cool to call
it the external evaluate framework but
the only place we call it that is in the
error messages which is a little weird
well what we do we so one of the
purposes of this is we want to document
the actual frameworks of people and
write their own right I understand
okay so um why don't you show this to me
on your machine yeah let me and then
you ready if it's so I screen here
that's just a big gray blob right now
I'm just saying I can see it yep okay
okay so so the the webdriver thing we
have webdriver - Firefox or webdriver -
chrome and if it works so one of the new
things that we're adding is we're adding
another key for how to specify the
system that session options like this
and right now the only option I have is
this headless argument so I just
realized one of session options relative
is that session options that would be
I'm confused here okay so so special
options is is different what that means
is this is an option to starting the
session so now necessary something
that's evaluated like how it's being
evaluated but how you start the session
I understand I think that isn't that a
piece of the start external session
thing why is it hidden I mean it do we
have other options that go along with
the name of the external evaluator yes
so you know for example you could do in
these are all just shorthand of the of
the full Association and the full
Association has a session options key is
that what you're saying yes yes
okay do we want to I mean in the case of
Headless it seems to me that's a very
different proposition a headless um
thing from a headed I mean I would have
thought that it would be webdriver
headless Firefox or something because I
think it's really a different thing from
a Firefox that's you know moving stuff
around in your screen
well surely what a headless one does
okay okay so here's you know okay so
this is what it looks like when you
don't when you don't use headphones so
you know I can doc you cool the way
let's see that you make your wonders boy
yeah what did you just do okay open web
page do why do you have to put um a list
on the right hand side yeah I mean yeah
you're right hey reg can you make a note
of that
yes okay
if so so it opens here this should be
returning null ignore the return value
there well what should it be returning
hold on hold on hold on hold on what
does external evaluate usually return
answer it usually returns the actual
value I mean couldn't it return
something more interesting from open I
mean what is what is the value when you
open a web page like what is anything I
don't know what is the webdriver
what is webdriver what is the webdriver
function return
I mean it it doesn't return anything
like it
because there's not like a return value
most of these external or most of these
webdriver operations aren't you know
something I mean there's a few you know
I kid one you know paid so yeah okay so
I could do page title they'll make sure
why you can also do current or capture
image I think let me just cut your web
page and then it'll give you you know an
image of of this right fairly large one
tygris monitor but you know here's your
so wait a second so that that is
analogous to our screen capture business
but that will do that wait a minute
that's just for the visible region of
the web page that's not for the actual
that's not the full rendered web page
that's just the visible region yes it's
it's exactly like you know our our
current screen image because it just
shows you what is visible on that part
of the screen now you could do something
like see if I have this so you can
change the size yeah I don't think
that's
right now but so you can change the size
of the browser programmatically and so
you could set it to be you know
something gigantic and then run this and
then you get a job yeah so this is what
you know what it worked a WebKit thing
doesn't the WebKit thing have a full
render of the whole web page it might I
haven't seen function expose that does
that
okay all right but where's the list of
functions that you are exposing and by
the way that page title thing is that I
think it's actually a web page okay okay
and what about the URL for example are
you
I mean no is that this correspond to so
one issue there is that we have this
whole web page mechanism for cloud
deploy that is supposed to be building
web pages it would be really nice if
these things agreed in the building up
right in the what is it an appearance
rules for cloud deploy you correctly
page titles and so on right so those
should agree with what you get back
forget each other yes yes I should go
look up what those I don't think that's
where you're going to find it but but go
ahead
didn't you just want me to open this
doctor no I think that the appearance
rules we were using that for cloud
deploy for webpages as I recall just saw
a nice example of this all right
that's not the there's something where
we have a convenient set of convenient
Association that we set up to represent
the elements of symbolically the element
to a webpage and what I'm saying is we
should make sure that we make those
agree with what we're doing with the web
driver thing okay yeah that's that's
fine so as you're saying you know for
example instead of a page title it did
you'd be like Kaiba I'm thinking yes
probably that that does agree or at
least we should allow cases where to
make that agree okay so let's keep going
so again where's your list of possible
commands effectively
we have you know things like JavaScript
executes locate element click element
type element right element boy okay have
you have you started documenting all of
this stuff so yeah we actually do have
documentation you know not perfect but
close to and those names are coming from
the names of JavaScript there what was
that about
is that part of install no no that's I
think there's a few of these that I
forgot
no these are all wrong sorry I don't
understand what these are are you
suggesting that there are individual
pages for each of these commands so what
I'm saying is there should not be
individual pages but so what's the plan
the plan is to have one page for
webdriver - Firefox yes there's one page
for you no I mean is that going to be
confusing I think it'll be enough right
and then we just have you know a big
table yes these things are mostly
one-line descriptions there's not going
to be something with a whole elaborate
story about what it does yeah for me for
the most part like open web page you
know like that's very straightforward
you know web page title a few of these
like the the locate element you know
those kind of things
what is located on dude I mean was it
returned some weird Dom thing yeah yeah
so it used to find if you know you want
to find the search bar in you know you
can I see what it widow's what how do we
represent the Dom element yeah because
no not all of these things I exposed it
so if I do ignore some of these coming
in some about I just wanted to because I
don't remember no returns I mean it
these things are not totally silly it's
not obvious why we want to hide all
these things inside external evaluative
a Firefox driver I mean open web page
does seem like a fairly useful function
similar to system open okay keep going I
want to see what it returns for the Dom
element
it was oh right sorry that's there's
different ways but that session ID is
what that's some kind of internal
pointer inside the web drive yet yeah
this is some big internal number that no
one is ever gonna want to actually see
you know you you'll have your own UUID
that maps yep yep okay but you know for
example this is something that if some
random thing that chrome uses to correct
IDs and so with whatever whatever this
is I could go and then say I mean so
actually locate element it's a bad
example because I can just do remove
this you can actually see a type click
on the element first and then we can
type it search and then I do type
element
oh right you know cuz these are dead oh
yeah sorry
so this is actually a difference
thing what is you mean now it's
different after you yeah it don't matter
when you click on it there's a different
okay so look this thing that's coming
back has got to be represented as some
kind of external object thing
you mean this kind of like IDE type
thing is what you're saying has to be
external right say that again I'm sorry
by the way we have a comment from the
live stream from Michael Hale saying a
few years ago he used phantom J's from
within often language to make renders of
a full webpage a whole page full scroll
yes I mean phantom genius and actually
the thing that we're using are you know
basically just wrappers around the same
thing I think that we just didn't we
just didn't see the API for the full
scroll basically of a web page okay fine
so that's just separate thing good well
I'm trying to understand is this is very
nice that you can get this element but
this should be represented as an
external object just like you know some
random pointer that comes back from some
other language don't you think I mean
didn't yeah I never pattern for external
object yeah we don't we don't have this
external object yet that's not I mean
it's not a thing yeah we yeah we should
make it a thing because that is a that's
that's a fine example of an external
object and you know to me that external
object should have you know I think it
should be some Association that says
what type of thing it is that we can
display symbolically in the language and
that contains its raw the raw
information inside okay so the raw data
or you know or raw I don't know what you
want to call it but but then this
external object has to be associated
with that specified external session
object
right it's an extra leg of an external
session
and then that wants to have a summary
blob that says what kind of thing it is
mm-hmm right and now if we do that then
this will look quite nice I mean if you
say no I'm a little concerned that the
actual syntax of that locate element
thing let's type in what that looks like
now so that would be an external
evaluate of s comma and then what would
it be quotes locate element yep
arrow and then what is that actually
going to be underscore nav search
actually be what's the ID thing there so
the ID thing is actually this there's
also just kind of unfortunate so there's
there's all these other like it's just
like XPath there's a CSS selector
element class name all these kind of
like different things that could be in
an HTML webpage okay an ID is I think
the most common one and I would be fine
with just making the decision that you
know this nav search is what it defaults
to and if you want to do something else
say you know you have another argument
works like XPath no I don't like that
because that's the type that's I mean in
if this was a proper symbolic thing in
our language there would be some wrapper
that says XPath yo right and so what we
have to do is emulate that here as best
we can I mean I think the most natural
way to do it would be a quotes ID arrow
now search
the key name ID and that you can put it
in the association if you want ID arrow
now search just like you'd say XPath
arrow that yeah I mean I think that's a
yeah that's probably the least grotesque
way to do it
and we could have a default if you want
to um that the locate element that means
that the documentation for locate
element is going to be slightly
complicated because it's going to have
to say locate element except yeah I mean
eventually perhaps we will have a more
cooked version of this I mean depending
on how I just don't know I don't know
how stable this kind of interface is I
mean it somehow reminds me of the I
don't know why it reminds me of this but
it reminds me of the printer driver
stuff that we didn't add in 1987 which
would be really humorously archaic in
today's world um so I just don't know
whether this is okay but but so let's I
think that's the right way to do this
obviously you can leave off the curly
braces and probably you can leave off
the Association wrapper then but having
the possibility that the you can specify
yeah so okay so this is well it's not I
mean it's not beautiful but it's not
totally grotesque yeah I mean I guess
you know the thing I'd be worried about
is you know for for the 11.3 timeframe I
think making this they even just making
this into a summary box thing I think
there's a lot no I agree I agree but but
let's look what we can do because you
don't make it into a summary box I think
just returning it would be useful okay
fair enough just wrap it without making
it yes because otherwise otherwise I
mean returning that point zero you know
point eight eight whatever it is I
assume that's a string
yeah well it's it's I don't know why
this is so weird I've never seen you my
d yeah in firefox it is that you chrome
is like this weird thing where it's you
know well probably somebody thought it
was it was good idea to have it shorter
because they weren't gonna have that
many I mean I have no idea what that is
um who knows but okay but in any case
that what what other symbolic elements
are there that come back out of this so
it could be returned well go ahead this
is so for some of some browsers not all
browsers support this is you can make
new windows let me see if I figure out
okay
by the way the type that you listed
under external object is it really
document ID what are those things called
that they're elements of the Dom aren't
they it's not a document idea yeah and
by the way the object itself is not an
ID the object is a I don't know what it
means web page element or something I
don't know but what is it it probably
has an official name which some
JavaScript enthusiasts would really know
yeah I know okay well here let's let's
but that you know the type of that is
going to be maybe a web page would be
another type which is your whole window
thing mm-hmm all right I want to know
what happens okay so you've got all
these commands here I want to know what
happens with them the headless thing
okay so this is what
for now right normally when I specified
this Firefox you know we had the you
know the window came up but it shows up
here yep now if I do
headless the window doesn't show up but
what do you actually do I mean is it is
it as if there's a off-screen frame
buffer or something that is it exactly
what it is okay so I can still do I see
so really the only difference is is it
just doesn't display which is why I
thought it would be make the most sense
as a session option because it's
literally exactly the same just launched
a headless let's just think about use
cases for a second okay
because the headless case I mean if you
want for example a picture of a web page
which I assume the guy I I thought we
were going to have something called web
image right just like we have we have
web image search we were going to have
web image that simply gives you
an image of that webpage you know what
is that what is what is the thing you
just did capture web page okay yeah yeah
you wanted to implement this it would
literally be like two - no I understand
that
which is but that's but that seems
useful I'm I mean yeah I mean except
that we got to deal with this issue what
are we doing so for screencap we've got
notebook capture and we've got screen
capture right that's right current
notebook image and that's that notebook
right nice and recursive and then we've
got current screen image which is but
now we've got current screen image
pointed out that notebook object right
which would only give the visible part
of that notebook yes
if I run it again you know we don't see
the entire
yes okay but so the function I mean
again this post eleven point three here
but the function web image or web I mean
I guess let's see we have web search and
web image search I guess this is webpage
image I guess
it's a little funky but
this is we don't have functions I mean
usually we would say things like you
know import from a URL right and this is
what the heck is this I mean this is
some weird other thing because otherwise
well we have URL read/write and we have
URL execute this is what's up you say
maybe this previously hooked up into an
import import format where you give it a
URL and it returns you I think that's
even more bizarre you know that's
usually import just brings in a bag of
bits and tries to sift through them and
turn them into something reasonable and
that's not he'll yeah okay you could
argue that's exactly what this is doing
except that's not how it works because
arguably that's what it's doing because
it's it's bringing in well that's
interesting
I mean so your point is that's
interesting um okay maybe we should I'm
just thinking what um I mean the other
thing look this is in the URL read URL
execute family I would assume because
what URL execute does is it brings back
the result of executing that URL right
and this is bringing back some rendered
version yeah I mean I guess what it is
yes that's right that this is you're
right that it's not that different from
import and you are Alexa can you just
look up your Alexa cute
okay that's the format option for URL
execute format argument for URL execute
and that over there's the one used by
import so I'm beginning to warm to your
idea yeah I mean it is like you know in
implementation wise it's nowhere near
the same thing you know you never see
the HTML or the bytes or anything but
you know it is
okay let's let's put this on the on the
list post eleven point three is is call
us still with us okay um okay
alright so let's come back so then the
question original question is headless
right I mean someone's points out on the
livestream that adding headless to the
name of the to the name of the thing
just okay
the only argument for that is just like
with Python for example we're adding you
know the name of the library and things
yeah so
no oh yeah um amazing fascinating you
know they call it range as well
interesting um okay
so
the question really okay so my next
question is do we actually need the
webdriver word we could we could get rid
of webdriver
I kind of like webdriver because you
know that's I mean that's like the
protocol that we're using is the
webdriver protocol and so there's some
might be some people who come from you
know I was using Java or selenium or
whatever other framework that uses
selenium uses webdriver in some other
programming environment and they see the
word webdriver and they're like oh I
know exactly what this is you know but
there's no what's what's the way to
drive I mean from if you have like
chromium or something is that that's a
thing that you could in principle call
not Chrome is that right I mean you know
it's there's an alternate what else
would you mean by saying external
evaluative Chrome I have no idea because
Chrome for the most part I mean there
are some command-line options you can
run you know like headless being one of
them but I mean as soon as the process
is started basically it's not meant to
be controlled except by from this
webdriver thing or through a user
clicking and typing and you know GUI
type things so
you know somebody points out in the
chance that webdriver is pretty industry
standard so I mean there's there's one
data point yeah right okay I'm concerned
about this headless thing because it
seems to me you know what we don't want
to do if the use case for the headless
one is completely different from the use
case for the non headless one it's kind
of goofy to hide all of that in some
weird option alright so I'm trying to
understand what the use case is the use
case for the non headless one is
probably that you're you know for
example your scripting some demo that
involves using a web page is that a fair
assessment where whereas the headless
one is much more I don't know you're
trying to do some way trying to what's
that
no QA testing like you're making sure
your website looks reasonable or no
search functionality works or something
like right I really think it's different
um I mean it's kind of annoying to just
type it out and let me see how
horrifying it looks webdriver Firefox
headless and is that even the right
order for it okay it's kind of
horrifying but perhaps less horrifying
than to have from
I mean it's less horrifying than to have
this weird session options thing that um
you know for something which is really a
different use case and just listed as a
separate type of you know in our list of
external evaluators this is a different
external evaluator I mean I know it's
just a command-line option but go ahead
we were gonna say well I'm gonna say in
terms of documentation we could just
have a note on you know the main web
driver Firefox page that just says hey
if you want to run a headless here's how
you do it and then some examples I don't
think we should do that because I think
people are different I think okay you
think about what the examples are as you
say the examples are different examples
because it's one case what's the use of
the non headless case the non headless
case I believe is primarily for demos do
you agree yeah yeah I mean it'd be kind
of interesting does one want the thing
which has a funky name to be the one
which is headed rather than headless if
I really yes I would say that probably
the most common use case will be if
someone wants to do this headless I
think headless is that I would think so
too common by these days but then what
would you call the headed version
visible
blah yeah it's weird it's very weird
look the fact is the headless no it's
horrible the headless I mean there's
another point that you know we could
just drop the web driver and then I
think you know Firefox that's headless
Firefox visible that shows up that's not
that terrible well but you just made an
argument for why web driver yeah
and I'm completely disregarding that let
me ask this question is there any other
way to drive Firefox other than through
webdriver
come on door oh the command-line options
don't really give you much I mean the
command-line options there's I think one
that I know of and that's specifically
for just generating you know a web image
where you give it an oxen let's go to
this URL capture the web page or capture
an image of it save it somewhere and
then exit that's that's literally know
so that wait wait I didn't know there
was a command line I had no idea that
web browsers had that command line
option these days that that um so in
other words that that is the thing that
one could use for you know this web
image web page image thing yeah yeah it
could be done you know completely
independently of all this stuff but I
would suggest not doing that because
there's a lot of machinery that think
here to find your firefox and you know
from the arguments and things like that
that this is gonna give me the same
thing and it's easier unified code base
okay notice that we've called it nodejs
not JavaScript and in one of our other
you know one external evaluators very
true and that is a you know
implementation level thing now I don't
actually what does that mean for this
hump
um what should we do here webdriver or
um no we've got some comments on the
this is very useful thank you guys um
yeah someone's pointing a right EB is
pointing out at some point you may need
to change the underlying API from
webdriver to something else
yes well okay the issue is is the
webdriver API hidden from orphan
language user because I'm concerned that
some of the things that we're offering
are I mean like for example the actual
is it the case that the actual commands
that we offer are the same between
Chrome and Firefox oh yeah the command
the command set is the same the
implementation is almost exactly the
same - a few little nitpicky things that
are differences between the webdriver
implementation for these different
browsers but by the way but this is this
works on all platforms right
yeah well Windows Linux Mac yep okay me
uh maybe not Raspberry Pi actually I
think it should work on some of them but
not all of them I don't know
okay um okay Michael Hale is saying it's
a well known protocol but I certainly
wish I could have set up an automated
app you are doing UI testing awhile ago
without ever having to learn the word
our windows that's an interesting name
for headed
alright okay hold on let's think about
this for a second I mean I'm kind of
leaning towards just saying Firefox and
Chrome yeah because I think I'm worried
okay how long has webdriver been around
I mean so the protocol I don't think is
even right okay I mean it's like
proposal I don't think it's been
approved yet yeah so did it
recommendation
you
I mean it's used very very heavily I
think it's highly unlikely that you know
it's just gonna fall to the dust at some
point but but it is not like an official
thing yeah well and the fact is that the
fact that there's a whole shtick you
know this is more analogous okay the
only thing that's weird here okay let me
make a further comment
so webdriver itself is a function based
interface if I'm understanding correctly
there's no webdriver language so to
speak unlike for example when we call
Python where we're dealing with the
Python language or is that well what is
the what is all of this well yeah I mean
it's there kind of is a language I mean
I mean it's an API it's like a protocol
let me find an example yeah so there's
all these like posts right you post a
session or you know get session back URL
timeouts forward etc etc so there is
kind of a language I mean it's just an
API of things that you're calling versus
you know over over no I understand but
the analogous thing to say no okay we've
got a bit of a confusion here because
you know if you say Python what you
expect to give in the string is a bunch
of Python code right here
you're not these are you know these are
HTTP requests basically they're so you
know in some weird sense the the thing
you would expect to do here is give a
list of HTTP requests and you'd be like
feeding this creature its list of HTTP
of symbolic HTTP requests and yeah
why am I reminded of logo turtle
commands um okay but then what we're
doing is translating those into AI this
is so complicated on evaluate thing that
we actually are using here so your
proposal is that what we're doing okay
so the idea that we had before was that
normally in a language like Python for
example that second argument would just
be a string the language string so to
speak if whereas here what we're doing
is we're saying there is this thing that
is our interpretation of those commands
from C I mean there's an argument
there's an argument that we should at
least support the roar commands that you
saw in that list from that webdriver
rotation because that will be the analog
of supporting a raw Python command there
yeah and and and the point then is that
those are
I mean arguably bizarrely somewhat
bizarrely you could actually have as a
second argument to the external evaluate
an HTTP request yeah because that would
that would package I mean I don't do
those things need other stuff in them
other than a single sort of payload I
guess a little complicated but no like I
mean it can be one of those external
object things yeah exactly you know kind
of like references to some random thing
like IDs but it can be multiple things
for example can it be I mean what can
you even put in a I mean in a post
request you can put all sorts of junk
yes I mean it's basically and so you
know this is an example of what you know
I guess you could do with Firefox or
something and I mean it come kind of
JSON object and so I don't think it's
totally unreasonable that this HTTP
request and you know you have your body
goes yeah I understand okay okay look
okay
what
is making me think is that ultimately
this is such a weird thing because in
okay we've never had yeah I mean hmm the
other thing we could do and this would
be a lot more working so this is not
going to 11.3 is is we could just say no
to the whole external evaluate framework
and we could just have individual
functions for all of these these things
and you know I think I was thinking
about something like that I mean I was
thinking about something where we have a
framework for basically just
manipulating webpages I mean it's very
similar to what we're doing for example
for the you know some of this stuff like
mail handling or something you're
manipulating some right I mean that's
probably what we should ultimately do
all right okay okay let's do the
following okay let's let's leave I mean
this is like defensive design here this
is all experimental stuff anyway let's
leave okay so right EB asks on this some
on the chat so now I guess the linear
algebra and the la pack package or JDBC
drivers in database link yeah I kind of
is I mean this is the low level
implementation I mean some of this stuff
already on github right but we're
packaging it in a way that's more right
more convenient okay so look here's what
I think we should do I think we should
go ahead and call it webdriver - Firefox
um and then webdriver - Firefox -
headless and okay I think then we should
use these you know we should use these
sort of cooked commands here that are
armed our mapping of the webdriver
standard okay what we should expect to
do once we have this all up and running
is to try and figure out whether we want
to have a framework more specific to web
page manipulation not inconsistent with
this but this this will allow us to you
know experiment with that by calling it
the webdriver thing we are since since
it is in fact yeah I mean we you know in
some sense the fact that it's Chrome or
Firefox is sort of irrelevant except
that in the headless case it's kind of
irrelevant who cares
at some level well maybe maybe you do
care because maybe it renders fonts
differently or something like this and
that's important for QA purposes perhaps
for QA and I think QA is gonna be a real
big usage of this yeah I mean I know our
our QA department has been doing things
like this for four decades basically but
but I think that they will be early
users of a better packaged version of
this
so I guess one thing that I figured out
what specifically dysfunctions find its
crash but when I was trying to show you
is that when we have a version of it no
I don't have so this data says that find
external evaluators returns he's going
to get gigantic
you know for example you know here for I
mean there's a lot of Python here but
you know if we're gonna have no Jess and
icon and maybe Pitt exactly yes there's
gonna be a whole bunch of these and so I
wanted to try and see what's your point
that there are a bunch of different
random versions of Python there no no my
point was that if we keep adding all of
these different slightly different
versions of a system this dataset is
gonna have a bunch of different like
system T's here so that'll be Python
Python - numpy there'll be you know
webdriver - Firefox webdriver - Firefox
ok fine but it gets huge people will
okay you know it'll it has its own ways
of dealing with that little paginate
it's fine I mean so there's lots of yeah
you just do open close it's like you're
you know you're listing all your files
or something yeah that's okay I mean too
much okay all right I mean yeah I don't
think there's an issue with that okay
you know data set is set up to deal with
long things okay so anything else that
we need to figure out right now I should
get going in a few minutes here I think
we'll need another meeting once the
design once the new dark steam is done
making that external evaluate system
right pieces though I mean so we've got
external object that you're going to
just start using here even though we're
not really ready with it but it'll be
okay and anything else you need to use
here it's the first time you're getting
back a pointer what what happens why
can't you get back pointers from I mean
what happens when you are returning some
Python pointer like object
this right is failure out there but we
can do string and you just get this it
doesn't turn into anything else but that
is the string form of the function as as
Python reports it but that's a pointer
that's a raw memory pointer is yeah it
is wrong so you could you ever feed that
in this session in that Python session
you could in principle feed that back in
so ultimately the version of that that
is an external object that invalidates
after this you know has a it uses our it
uses the session ID you know the UUID
for that python session right and so it
knows it's only valid for that session
and then it could perfectly happily be
fed back in again yeah yeah I think that
I guess what I'm getting tripped up on
is that I don't know if Python actually
will let you do that although the
languages probably do that you just
dereference pointers like that mostly on
something you just go stop yeah sure
finger and it'll crash or whatever yeah
exactly
I think Python doesn't let you do that
but in principle you could yeah you
could feed it back in okay all right
it's not anything else we need to figure
out right now I guess
quick question so if I'm gonna do this
do you want this import format or no oh
yeah I mean if we look by the way
Michael hell is pointing out on our live
stream it's it's absolutely I could but
people try to take picture of a webpage
they shouldn't have to know anything
related to webdriver a hundred percent
degree the UM and I think this would be
reasonable compromise for that it's just
you know we document the web image you
know I guess format and they just search
web image they see the format I think
it's a little weird I think we probably
want okay I think we want to function to
do that and I don't yet 100% know what
it should be
I'm guessing it's web image but it may
need some tentacles you know for example
yeah I mean the problem is as soon as
people have that they're going to say
can't I before I take the image can't I
scroll down
right true and then they're going to be
thrown into having various kinds of you
know then they're going to be thrown
into a full webpage manipulation
framework or you know can't I enter this
in the I mean you know many web pages
like you know you got a wolf now for or
something you just you can just put
stuff in the URL line to you know
actually it's very string right but um
but not every site is like some other
weird graphical user interface thing and
that's what somebody on what this
suggests look ultimately the right
answer here and and I don't know you
know this is a general problem that we
have okay
just to editorialize for a moment you
know they're a bunch of these situations
in which we are trying to represent an
external language or language like thing
symbolically so for example the case
weather has come up recently is the
etherium virtual machine alright how do
we represent the commands of the
etherium virtual machine and you know I
think we're gonna represent them by some
kind of external command wrapper that
says what type of you know that it's for
the for the etherion virtual machine but
it it's a this is a bit like that except
that there isn't you know it is a set of
command you know function like things
except it's not really a language I mean
somebody could make a language like we
can make a language that is a web page
manipulation language and if we're gonna
do that we it should be sort of full
symbolic yeah I mean it does seem to
make quite a bit of sense to me the only
thing that is frustrating about it is
that unlike most of what we do where you
are operating on a symbolic expression
that you're kind of holding yourself and
where you know you are sort of more or
less immutably operating on things and
returning stuff in the case of a web
page it's like a number of things we're
doing recently like the mail handling
stuff where you've got this thing out
there and you're poking at it like you
know more like sort of traditional
object-oriented programming stuff and
it's kind of a shame that we can't think
that we have
just editing izing here but you know
that we can't think we have essentially
a symbolic representation of the webpage
that we are you know okay right that
we're poking out and doing things just
like we would normally do I mean it's
sort of interesting we were just working
on just today actually the the end of
the mail handling business okay and
what's kind of interesting there is that
when you like have a mail folder what
you're bringing in are basically a bunch
of symbolic objects that represent mail
items that are mail messages and you can
you know manipulate that and you can do
selections on that and things like this
okay anyway I think we've got a
direction for what we need to do for
this you know 11th hour 11.3 thing let's
go ahead and do it in this slightly
defensive way expecting that we will
make it less defensive as we understand
more about how to make a proper symbolic
representation for web pages sound
reasonable and okay that sounds okay do
i okay if you can unshare and I will
save out I did I have I have stuff to
save out right from earlier I don't I
don't think so because I mean I just
sent you the example in the book that I
made for the dark steam no no no I mean
I have stuff to save out from the the
stuff we did on network packet go here
yes sorry on CD okay all right well
thanks for the comments from the
livestream and thank you in and color
and so on and we'll look at this one
more time
and look forward to seeing it